you know when you mix comedy and horror
you're walking a really it's a thin line
it's like oh you know it could be too I
was just talking to your publicist
Camellia who's awesome and I was just
saying you know that you know sometimes
you get these guys they're just they
just want to make it funny and be goofy
and it takes you out and this didn't it
never took me out of the movie man it
was like yeah it was like those three
guys and the old guy they have these
conversations but when they get brutal
it's dark it is [__] dark and you're
like yes stay there stay there and your
character I haven't seen you play a
character like that but you're so
reserved and very like oh my God this
guy is gonna snap sometime uh who's he
gonna snap on and it was it was just
very well thought out the dialogue was
good
um you know little things like of of her
what's her character's name again Becky
Becky Becky I just [__] it's in the
title you idiot
um no but Becky Becky like you know
she's in the scene and she's she's a
waitress and this guy says darling and
kind of belittles her and she's looking
at him like huh and then she slits his
throat in a certain way I don't want to
give it any way which I just did but
then you realize it's just in her mind
that idea you're like oh but it's so
vicious and you think things are gonna
happen you're like oh this is gonna
happen and it doesn't and when it gets
going like if you like movies like
there's a movie see-soo
[Music]
it's brilliant and this has this it's in
the same vein it's in the same vein as
that's in the same vein of nobody with
Bob Odenkirk who I love who he came on
the podcast yeah I haven't seen that but
that looked great oh dude and it's like
it's just really fun to watch and it's
got some shocking moments and some
Hilarious Moments and and the lead
characters she's she's so good and she's
like so good it really thank you for
saying I'm so glad that I swear I
wouldn't say it I felt the same way when
I watched it because
um you know for me I think I only shot
for like one week and and all my stuff
is in one location so there's so much
that they shot that I didn't see and
um
so it's such a treat to watch and I was
like holy book everything you just said
it worked because you know when you're
shooting these smaller movies and the
movie doesn't look small at all but um
you never know yeah and you're like you
don't know you know you just and it was
one of those experiences too that you
know just creatively and personally you
know these smaller movies like was just
really fulfilling you know you're kind
of you have a close group people like
it's a smaller crew and
um so you go like all right well the
experience was fantastic
um if it works then great but when I
watched it it was everything you just
said it was like it was such a tight
movie and they uh Matt Angel and Suzanne
the writer directors they nailed the
tone I want to work with them you tell
them I want to be in a movie with those
guys they know what they're doing I will
definitely tell them they would love
that they know what they're doing and
you know I mean I wonder if like when
they sent you this script because the
script's great but I bet there's one
part of it that you that's the reason
you took the role
can I say can I can I guess can I guess
yeah it's the monologue you tell them
about squeezing the guy oh yeah well
it's a good story to that because
um yeah so they sent me the script I
hadn't seen the first Becky and I
actually hadn't worked for almost a year
because I was doing a TV show and you
know how it is you're like in a weird
holding pattern and it kind of [__] you
with like other projects
and so then this thing came around and I
had like a little window and when I read
the script I loved the script and the
part I just I guess it it I couldn't
figure out really how what to do with it
and then it just had some ideas and I
wanted to see if they'd be open to hear
my ideas and they were and so
you know one of them they had a
monologue in there but I said
what if the guy you know because with
that monologue and you don't have that
much time that you spend with this
character is like here's an opportunity
to really share who this guy is create
more of a threat
um and get an idea of his history so it
just raises the stakes and I just said
if you had you know there's you know x
uh Army Ranger
that whole monologue came it was like a
combination of like
you know it was a real collaboration and
I shared these ideas and they were so
awesome about it they rewrote that
monologue and when I read I was like
[__] yeah like that was it for me and
that really informed the rest of the
characters so the character became quite
different than what was on the page and
again it was like
you know never having a chance to do
something like this it was really
fantastic to have filmmakers that
believed in me and believed in some of
these ideas and it made it
um
that just made it a great experience and
then you know to hear you know someone
like yourself like liked it
it was a it was a treat because you
never know anything like this I know and
you're right about character it's like a
lot of times they'll just have oh these
are bad guys but when you have backstory
when you have backstory um subtext to a
character and you have a little insight
to what he can do it makes everything
more every you just kind of go oh oh oh
this guy yes got a dark side and it just
doesn't Skip by that beat it I love that
beat it's important for the movie and
yeah it's it's really good I mean
there's some great lines there's like I
always love like when I watch Return of
the Living Dead one of my favorite
movies it's hilarious it's dark but like
there's all these lines in it that I
just remember
um and like there's there's lines like
uh you know she says one of the
characters says I guess you guess you
missed my brain
oh yeah I was just like holy [__] yeah
that is
that is [__] awesome you guys also
see it I'm not gonna wait yeah how about
when um uh sorry to cut you off but like
one of my favorites though is when um
The Twig character
um
when he's like he's on the ground he's
like no no I promise I'll stop saying
bad things about women like I am a kid
get out please and and she's just about
to get him she goes what's his name
what's his son's name performances
according to games he's like
it's Adolf and he's just like yeah yeah
I'm gonna teach my son morals I'm gonna
teach him I'm gonna make sure he does
he's a good boy what's your son's name
Adolf
like he's raising a Nazi yes I I died
that's I mean there's all there's so
many little gems in there
and it's dark if you're a horror fan
you're gonna love it if you like comedy
you're gonna love it it's just that shot
well the acting's Great